[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
GameSpot I'm like mehar to your host I'm
here playing pray which releases Friday
with lead system shiner designer
Seth Shane let's make getting tripped up
already and lead level designer rich
Wilson well thank you so much for
joining us all the way from arcane and
Austin that's right yeah you guys
probably pretty excited games about to
come out super excited yeah quite gonna
play a couple missions here right or
like a couple stretches of the game yeah
that people have people seen these yet
or no yeah we've shown some of the stuff
off before but it always goes a little
differently cool so it's always worth
reviewing awesome one of the alluring
aspects of scheme right immersive sim
kind of emergent gameplay mm-hmm yeah
this thing's pretty dangerous and I can
ignore it or I can deal with it there's
several ways you can deal with this like
you can just kind of glue it which will
kind of make the hazard kind of
addiction for the hazard make our parrot
permanently
otherwise this glues gonna break in a
little while so I'm just gonna keep
moving okay what that I've like shocked
you if you try walking yeah eventually
this is the the glues gonna break on
this and it's gonna start being a hazard
again and it's really dangerous
okay so we're in the psychotronics lab
it's basically when they've been
researching aliens developing technology
and and things based on the aliens sort
of DNA or their their makeup okay um and
where things kind of went wrong
cool yeah as like a level designer rich
the thing I want to ask you is I know
obviously arcane's other property
dishonours more discreet levels that you
can jump into and then finish and then
get forward to the next one this is one
big open mission how does that factor
into like your thoughts on level design
in this game when you're approaching it
so it's a completely different animal
from doing discrete levels it's much
more intense on the testing side as well
because you can come back to any level
with any powers at any point in the game
okay and you can also visit a lot of
things you before you're technically
supposed to before like the main story
beats happen in that level okay so we
have to make sure that the player knows
that they're in an area that they're not
technically supposed to be in or they're
there they're kind of going off the
beaten path and and we're okay with that
but we just want you know the player
needs to know like okay you're kind of
an extra space and things like that so
we can do things that are more
challenging so if they wander into an
area that might be an alien there that's
just way
outclasses them basically okay but they
know that they're not on the main path
and they're okay to explore things like
that are you are using a touch pad with
Nerf darts right now uh well they're not
nerfed science but yeah they are flow
charts Lexi Lexi phone
I saw the from the demo people using it
to shoot like door switches I didn't
know you can shooting like I I'm using a
lot of branding didn't know you'd be
shooting touchpads yeah we have emails
in the game that talked about how they
added capacitive tips so they could
screw with other employees and that's
what their workstations guys yeah yeah
so this is a security room and you know
there's some some enticing pickups in
here that I wanted to get and that was
just one way to get in like the player
could have you mimicked a small object
and gone through the glass right could
have found the the actual code to the
room later on and come back and it's an
optional space as well so it's awesome
yeah so that will the crossbow start
having more lethal ammunition later on
is we talking about that if you're
creative you can use it in with
destructive effects like okay we have
these things in the game that like look
kind of like grenades like people kind
of refer to those grenades because it's
shorthand for there we call the charges
okay because it really makes sense to
have a grenade on that space station
right but so like but these can be
thrown or they can be placed which is
kind of a something that most grenades
can't do so you can place them like a
mine okay and then when you do this it's
a proximity mine essentially also like
one of the things that the flux seafoam
darts can do is trigger those to
detonate it's interesting how all the
tools we've seen so far
makes sense of a Space Station like
you're saying there won't be grenades
but there could be charges maybe for
like engineering kind of construction
work yeah the foam dart bang like you
just said is the like employees mess
with each other I mean obviously has a
security system too but I guess every
space station needs a few turrets
I brought the turd in here because I've
done this a multiple times in it I know
this guy's waiting ambush me I turn the
tides on him so what kind of enemy was
that bipedal one that was the Phantom
it's like I mean foot soldier of for the
- ecology and so this is like an
alternate universe where JFK survived
corrected or maybe there wasn't even an
assassination I'm not completely sure
but and then like that changed how the
space race evolved that's super
interesting to me I'm a big fan of like
11/22/63 the Stephen King book
take it you're just using ugh
so using this this is a human power it's
not an alien power is called comment
focus okay and it's a kind of like
getting a big adrenaline rush or
something it enables the player to move
a little faster relative to the enemies
and okay you consume a little less
stamina when you swing your wrench come
and later levels you can even like dude
a more damage and stuff and it gives the
human power focused player is something
that they can spend sion also if they
want to be mainly you know a good point
flesh and blood then cool so I don't
know how much of a spoiler this would be
but a notic just keep comparing things
to Dishonored
but in this honor tou when you come in
contact with the outsider you can elect
not to take the powers and you can just
do a gadget solely run or just human
only is there opportunity to do
something like that and this yes cool
okay
just sticking to and making just going
down the engineer path almost like
hacker path rather than becoming an
alien yeah that's part of our like part
of the design challenge of making the
levels as well is that every you know
solution has to include a solution for
the player that doesn't take an alien
power here and has to be interesting for
the people that don't take alien powers
and that take Balian power okay either
where you go it has to be something
interesting and challenging my inventory
was full so I can pick some stuff up so
I just dropped a bunch of stuff and put
a recycler charge so I can demonstrate
how the quest not home Vulcan detonated
and so all that stuff I just shot from
inventory is like now like useful stuff
yeah so this is these are the crafting
materials that the player can use to so
that we have weaker these fat crafting
materials and you can use these in the
fabricator to create other things like
ammo and make okay some of this was the
stuff you dropped less valuable than
what you just got to fire ahead mostly
okay so I already have a glue gun and a
pistol so it's just like I don't need
those so okay so you pick up multiple
glue guns if you want yeah I was
thinking yeah you would pick it up and
you just have it in your inventory yeah
oh yeah cuz already I already have one
so
and now those supplies can go toward
upgrades as well stuff like that yeah
yeah you can you can create weapon
upgrades you can create new mods and I
can use all this all there's all these
different ways of upgrading your
character cool so this is the psycho
scope it's kind of our one of our key
devices we can use it to scam aliens and
get their powers and use them against
aliens face cream okay and when you the
first time you pick it up we like to
make sure the player starts with an
opportunity to get this mimic detection
chipset so the chips that you install in
your in your sega scope so as soon as
you have your second school be open
these slots so you can start doing this
from the beginning we have some slots
for the suit to suit chipsets and
chipsets and the one i just installed on
the scope is cool because it will let
players players at this point have like
seen the whole like mimic thing enough
we're like there's things this guys in
the environment ax and so like this is
our way of saying like now you can get
the jump on the mimics okay cool you can
detect them before before they
experience a bio awesome i said that was
gen one like can you start detecting
more at a time so you upgrade it or
something similar does it so yeah
there's another one that you can detect
more advanced mimics and then there are
other aliens that kind of have have
hidden features are the ability to hide
yeah well you ever pick up weapons that
are mimics um believe that yeah they can
they can mimic weapon yeah cool let's
get up yeah it's gonna mess with me so
much anything dynamic in the environment
they can they can dynamically become
that object it's really I'll be on edge
in a good way the whole time right it's
not just like so I could be backtracking
with new weapons and stuff and maybe be
off-guard and still we're
they make out of nowhere cool yeah reach
reversal is a big part of this game it's
it's it's much more open than like just
like soldered was like a linear
progression of missions for example this
is more like an open be called open
space station it's yeah we'd let the
player kind of free roam to infect any
spaces they've been to what do science
operators function is so this is like a
friendly robot that lives in the in the
world and it has a purpose it's like
ever cover a research assistant and my
sidebar which is the purple one on the
bottom that's like when I spend my
powers on and it will actually fill that
okay um if it's a helped Halloween yeah
we can get corrupted by so there's be
any ways that the world itself changes
throughout like based on your decisions
well things become more dangerous or
more conducive to win play style or
something like that so the world does
change over time without getting into
committee specifics that are kind of
spoiler territory the world does does
evolve over the course of the game not
necessarily in response to your actions
not the world at least there are there
are other things that your actions will
will cause other ramifications come but
yeah the world is kind of changing over
the course of the game cool yeah I
remind me again dishonored where you
know like more hi chaos approach and
more rational over run full of blood
fire or not yeah we don't have a chaos
system in the game any gain is much less
focused on self and much more focused on
like some action but there are some
humans in this station and and you know
or totally supporting a non-lethal slave
through for humans okay we expect you to
kill aliens yeah they're monsters sure
but the humans you don't you can use
this disruptor stun gun to neutralize
them and if some other ways you can
utilize them too okay
and there are friendly humans as well we
also support a completely lethal
playthrough so you can you can kill
anybody
that you meet and you know again there's
not like a chaos system where we're sort
of judging you but like that person will
be able to
a weapon later on okay so there are you
know consequences that are just
naturally kind of coming out of your
actions cool so that's the recycler
there which is a cool device too
it's like the it's it's kind of a placed
version of the charge right and just
like a little bit more efficient I think
to use but there is this hazard in the
way so I kind of want to get rid of it
and be comfortable so it doesn't pop
into my back so what I'll do is I'll
demonstrate that like I need repair to
to deal with this so I can install the
repair tuner Ahmad and then I can
hopefully hopefully fix it now I have
repaired to be out of time if I have
enough yeah if I have enough time and
spare parts and I don't have spare parts
so spare parts are something that you
find in the world but it's also rid of
those weapons okay well I'm not gonna be
able to do this then you can go take
down that science operator get the spare
parts on them so you could have recycles
well it's good for you oh oh oh if you
say so you could have if you had like an
extra weapon you didn't need you could
have used that to get spare parts
through the recycler yes okay well
nothing to recycle if there's a skill
you have that you can break down robots
and weapons and get spare parts out of
them gotcha
yeah once
with its screaming I just thought like I
think the orchestral kind of yeah okay
so that would feel awful if yeah so
there are spare parts in here but I need
this dismantle ability so that's another
neuroma that it can install called
dismantle you know I can now I can loot
this extra thing the only one though we
have we have another ability called
necropsy which lets you grip get harvest
more organs of the aliens and then you
can use all that stuff to to like make
your mods and stuff okay
this is I think maybe I just put it up a
little on it have enough time to use
this thing
like an insta-kill if it does hey it's
pretty damaging pretty low and it will
stun you too and it would like disable
your tech weapons - it's like this you
know high voltage electrical charge so
it kind of disrupts your weapons and
stuff Thanks so if there was like a
mimic in there and it hit you you might
be resigned to just your wrench yeah
thank your pistol and shotgun will still
work okay this is the ammo screens will
kind of go play gotcha us you might not
know how many shotgun shells you have
left before there's like I'm a making a
fabricator okay that's a little
sculpture there yeah kinetic art yes
this is the fabricator so I can do
things like make a sauce I hypo or and
this purple ingredient here that's the
what the aliens recycle into its like
exotic material
that's dangerous against I'm just gonna
keep moving there's a lot to do in this
level so you're still in the second
Tronics area we're like this is where
alan research takes place you're saying
exactly yeah this is um actually the
original satellite where alien life was
encountered and the whole space station
was built around with satellite what is
this
so that's a weaver they create the stuff
that you see that sort of golden
filaments behind it that we basically
call coral okay they they create that as
well as they can turn human corpses and
defendants yeah oh man
and if you scan Weaver's enough times
you can learn how to do that and then
it's all that as an ER Bob and then you
can turn corpses into phantoms that are
friendly
oh man you just have this you become
like a necromancer yeah yeah it's
awesome you figure a little oh my god I
feel like I'm just getting go through
that the first time I play
only human corpses yeah correct cuz I
looks like alien parts are kinda just
dispersed when you kill mostly yeah and
they leave behind that exotic material
stuff so I've been using this kinetic
blast ability which I learned for the
Phantom's connect blast is essentially
like a psionic grenade that's not like
to think about it and by the time you
get to this point in the game and you'd
been dealing with like swarms of mimics
and pandas hiding around corners and
stuff you kind of hungry for something
like a grenade yeah I think it's pretty
handy so you could theoretically come
around with what's the mod that
recognizes mimics the nimac detection of
us chipset chipset so you could be
coming up on a room and would you be
able to see through the walls of their
mimics in there do they have to be gonna
be okay gotcha yeah so it's a good it's
a good habit like when you're entering
into space til I kind of scan around to
see if there's any mimics lurking about
okay bubbling sighs tops go to that
armory solid punch in the code so this
guy's offering you a code to an armory
if you set him free but you look at his
record there and see it he's been
supposedly in prison for some awful
things so now it's kind of up to the
player to decide if they wanted to mulch
this guy or aren't you huh yeah so this
is like this facility is it's used for
creating exotic materials to in order to
manufacture their mods yeah an indirect
sort of way yeah I mean also it's like
you know used for scientist is kind of
study the whole process as well with
psycho scopes and stuff
yes Obie this is happening these guys
are called the volunteers it's kind of a
you know a spin on what they actually
are there you know prisoners that were
taken up from the gravity well from okay
Russia or whatever and brought up here
to be test subjects
okay so I can open the door I can
release the
[Music]
yeah really Semitic it seems like a
scumbag you yes what get some valuable
research yeah no now I can learn new it
three go oh my god
well then so what has just happened to
him his essence drained by the mimic
engine it was used to make more mimics
okay and that's how the outbreak began
me oh so you multiply yeah exactly
okay so that's so the the plus side of
that aside from just you know kind of
being not releasing that terrible
prisoner was that you got more research
as opposed to you would have gotten like
weapons ammo if you let him go yeah cuz
he had the code to that room right as
well as there's a machine here designed
to extract the material from these
mimics that have been created okay
did you hesitate and I hit the right
bunny so theoretically is there still a
way to get into the room he mentioned
yes okay also this is an arcane view
yeah so there's usually never one way
into a room or one solution yeah exactly
so now that I know that he's dead and I
won't be able to figure out I mean I
could probably guess 2,000 times or cuz
use hyper tree so let's do is in its we
don't answer that
I don't realize the symmetry until now
but basically you can scan those minutes
and learn how to get into the wound
yeah the same setup in what way because
you have so now that he now that he is
scan mimics he can mimic things as well
and that's another way into that same oh
I got it okay
kind of indirect way rewarding you for
not releasing him
not that you're judging the players game
but a big guy
okay that was a thief anthem so as you
progress through the game the Phantom's
start to come in different flavors
there's the bass phantom which is the
one I found earlier but then they start
you start running into these like elite
phantoms yeah and they have like some
kind of like element or something like
there's a there's a thermal one and
we'll take one okay that was great I'll
take it great those yeah kind of opaque
phantoms function oh and I'll be able to
my god I'll hit their next so that was
one thing based on the demo and based on
things you guys are pretty tight-lipped
about a lot that's going on this game
for good reason a lot of is that
discovery that emergent gameplay that'll
happen but people were wondering what
how enemies are going to kind of evolve
throughout so because I think we've seen
mimics so many times in trailers and
demos and whatnot that it's it's it's
interesting to hear that you're talking
there's different varieties of these
aliens which is pretty exciting yeah so
I just make that little bin and snuck
through that slot okay in the window now
I'm in here so now I get to get the
weapons he mentioned anyway thank you
awesome oh now we can dismantle stuff
not enough space and then alternatively
you could have just gotten hacking 3
later on the games and come all the way
back here to the room ok this mantle can
by this play the campaign you probably
could have gotten hacking 3 anyway ok or
you can let the guy out and then stun
him unconscious and then dragging back
in there and do the process anyway and
yeah we mentioned before we went live
but this is about three or four hours
give or take into the game roughly
although we've been seeing like you know
the first hour demo a lot of people have
been spending like two or three hours in
the demo yeah so you know our games
especially like Dishonored in this kind
of game people can can blaze through it
but not super fast but that you know
faster than the people that want to take
their time and scour and kind of soak in
the atmosphere sure and just a kind of
experiment with different like
overlapping systems and whatnot mm-hm or
explore side content like there are a
lot of rooms in this level in art you
know vitals we're getting to the game
but you get a lot of reports inside that
writing around
[Music]
then all the while you know you can well
I mean throughout the game you can also
explore like zero G's outside of the
space station correct lose I just
increase your armor or something and
repair your armor parts inventory system
kind of a resonable for flavor almost
mm-hmm yeah okay we're blowing a
Christmas dog during experiments
security protocol say this is another
experiment back in the 60s and 70s
involving the Weaver end and the bodies
like I mentioned earlier okay we were
being the one that creates aliens from
the courses currently developed in
intentional so there's a corpse in here
already
they don't know spatial their own
language they don't seem to even seems
oh man I'm being roll tankini the shorts
out the entire containment systems will
come out oh damn let's see their full
debuff and that could affect other
electronic systems around him and and
your weapons out as well yeah definitely
pretty resourceful when you're fighting
these ones yeah that's great he's
totally worked
you hit it with a wrench they're like
you launch it at him yeah exactly
sometimes that usually doesn't work I
mean it always worked but usually
backslash backfires oh there's another
one
and then you're also doing that slowdown
power in the process laughing hell yeah
there goes oh damn
he's uh that's nothing any good he's
electrical itself you pulled your chakra
or not right now if you don't remember
how many shells you guys you probably
wouldn't know yeah yeah oh that's
hanging it shot really great and there's
ways I can disabled sky like I could use
this no wave transmitter which is like a
way of canceling signing ability so he
like loses his his little aura of okay
danger which was at the kinetic grenade
right there I was like okay class so our
combat model is really focused on
combining things so like you want to
disable the inter meet your enemies in
order to to maximize like your resource
economy yeah like you don't want to if
you for instance if you're fighting
something really tanky like a telepath
or whatever if you are just shooting it
with the pistol you're gonna be spitting
a lot more bullets than if you stun it
first
sure or you like sign Elif I first cool
and then I the one the glue gun wrench
one seems pretty solid against normal
mimics at the beginning or it's one of
the viable options
are you pretty excited have you so have
you seen anything any players doing
something in the demo that you didn't
think of already yeah yeah the the bank
shot I think that's probably most
popular ones at this point basically
we've got a room in the demo in the
lobby that we didn't anticipate players
with the applicate into like it wasn't
you know it wasn't a big deal if they
did necessarily was going to break
anything but it was a room that was
locked with a key card door and there's
another like a window you can get in if
you have mimicked or something like that
right yeah but you weren't gonna be able
to get mimic in the demo so we're out
okay you know we didn't think about it
stitched thumbs slipped in some
resourceful players we're using glue to
place a glueball through the window and
in bank shots of the rubber darts off of
that glue ball and hit the button on the
other side that's awesome
without even having seen the button that
was you know remarkable there's a rate
there's probably half of that level that
we didn't explore by the way well yeah I
just kind of fast-tracked through the
psychotronics the what we're just and
yeah okay but until we kind of got to
the point in that level where we're
ready to go to the next one but rather
than go there I'd like to skip ahead to
the quarters cool is this a little
farther in the game I'm assuming yeah
okay close to the halfway mark I would
say yeah something like that
yeah I got a range for what you expect
players to beat this game in if they
were like when I wanted playing semi
completionist um I would say a
completionist I mean people can spend
around like 40 hours or something like
that like you needed something like that
2244 i depends um it's a it's a pretty
solid chunk of a game cool so this is
the the cou facilities like it's called
crew quarters right for presidential
looking than the psyche annex and it is
like you know there's this um this space
station exchange it's like the size of a
like the Empire State Building or
something right so it's this huge
facility and and the people who come to
work there it's like the best minds are
recruited to work here yeah and so they
create this really posh residential area
okay so that it feels like a calm place
you want to live cool
so this poor human is my control and if
I get too close to them they are going
to they can't really help themselves
let's just find out
whoa that's not what I thought it
happened what you said you mentioned
like a telepath is that the telepaths
doing yeah okay Kent over this little
well so seeing you triggered that
yeah those those guys are like they're
because they're being told by the
telepath and tell that's all so they're
they're hostile okay and you know if if
their head explodes then that person you
know obviously they're dead without
their head and there's ways the player
can can kind of prevent that from
happening by like for instance using
this disruptor okay stun-pistol that I
have so is a telepath kind of using them
as like walking mine's almost because
that well that would that have hurt you
if you're closer to him yes
oh damn that's crazy how many blood or
not yeah so it's basically like you
choose you can kind of sneak up on them
take now like wanted to find this way oh
that one yeah there's a couple of the
tricks to like you can um he's a no way
for need uh yeah break the smell yep no
you wanna kill you you are no more
prophets
psycho shopping ones uh Velma yes and
actually that's a really useful ability
to have against the telepath
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I know before we get teeth into this
it's going to that's a really fast quick
safe yeah we tried to make saving
painless as possible so that there's
good experiment and try try screws and
stuff and the quick load is right there
too so you can just talk right back nice
like a shock this thing looks blister
whoops so once once you uh well like
worried about this guy before after the
questions so if you're getting too close
this guy can he start taking over your
mind is that what he's trying to do he
yeah exactly but I have a second scope
on okay so it's like a mind shield yeah
and if I try to get close to him to like
he will just Holly and push me all back
back away
gotcha and it's like mega damage so
there's a couple ways to deal with this
guy
one is to like no wave them because
these thing and he'll don't wave me
these projectiles will we'll know we've
me prevent me from using my powers oh
that's all you have to dodge the money
but your gear is you can use that yeah
but I just know waved him so now he
can't use his power switch musics pretty
much has nothing to do and so he usually
runs away
that happens like a chess match almost
just with guns
[Music]
and then there's this weapon we have
called the Q beam which like excites
it's sort of like it inject a lot of
energy into things so that it's like the
particles and then explodes it's like
King Doug yeah okay like that okay so so
that like if he had full health it up
obviously would have taken longer to
over itis particles and stuff oh yeah
and if you stop shooting it the green
bar starts to kind of drain back down
okay and so what happens sometimes it's
like you're shooting them and then you
run out of QV memo so you can't quite
finish it yeah well you can use you can
start damaging them so that the red bar
catches the bow so my meat that's all
sex okay oh I thought I didn't always
think that's really fun to do is the
cubing the only thing you can like
increase their energy weather or their
other ways to do that well if you if an
enemy explodes from the Q beam if
there's enemies within proximity they'll
also take cubes flashed into chains and
so if you have yeah if you have like a
bus swarm of mimics or something and you
hit one in the center um like sometimes
it's enough to get the other ones either
to the point where they'll also explode
yes or like it's only takes very little
you just kind of go right over them a
niche pop [ __ ] okay cool so what when
you save those people from the telepath
and they went unconscious what can you
almost decide what can you do with their
corpses and I mean that and like the
most functional way in this game like
look could you have are there when there
are corpses there unconscious so like
yeah could you have helped them further
or gotten anything out of that situation
with that I think you can loot them okay
yeah we can drag them to safety apart
from them not being like walking mines
anymore and I think you can turn them
into phantoms okay yeah but they're also
basically counter as saved for the
purposes of like the narrative and
in-game stuff cool cuz we don't want
players have to manage like we're
bagging someone to multiple levels area
they the totally lootable
ostensibly if you wanted to make a
little game for yourself could you carry
that guy Caleb to the end of the game
you can't level transition with corpse
or items it's not like I know him from I
was a leopard had to noam chomsky order
we did have a programmer who you know
working a lot of physics so she had some
sort of a morbid fascination with rag
dolls I guess
she would make corpse piles in every
level okay just drag every corpse in
every level purely her performance
testing isn't I think she just has wears
a Q stand for is it quasiparticle I
believe okay I just pick as much
inspiration from real science as we can
and then you know sure as long as it's
fun for game playing yeah and consistent
within this world - exactly a good
sci-fi we have this system it's called
the roster system and it like let you
let's you like track people down
everybody on the entire station is
accounted for in the rosters okay system
and so yeah so that's where the Emma is
over there
I'm abating yeah and that's how she
found of corpses or you can show yeah
and then she killed them and then made
piles yeah okay yeah so what what is the
did this just become a mini side mission
to track that specific woman or is she
part of the main it's it all depends so
what we made the roster system basically
a system so it's it it exists
independent of any specific quest so in
some cases you may read an email about
oh I gave something to Emma or whatever
and then you like you'll be like okay
well I'll go figure out where she is by
going to the roster system and then you
can find her I can find people across
like across levels as well she could
have been like in the Arboretum or the
back in psychotronics somewhere else
he's exactly and you'll get markers that
lead you all the way to the person in
the and clan where they are so you can
sift through emails find a name that
interests you because they have a code
or they have something useful and then
see them across the station go find them
correct
so it gives you a sort of self-directed
mini quests but holy so I'm just show up
the research page here the first time
you scan something you get like some
lower about it and you like learn some
tactical information and then as you
scan you unlock new abilities and stuff
and then when you scan them completely
you get Morgan's notes about them and
sometimes there's extra a little little
bits in there that are that are
interesting or horse
we're helpful Morgan makes a little
painting of every monster in cm cameras
[Music]
these are like I saw Fitness Center
there's a still above or like
residential kind of living quarters
reason that these are the cabins really
be better off or the higher up crew
members base when they get individual
cabins then the rest of the people
sleeping these sort of Japanese Hotel
style pods okay so you just did what you
mentioned earlier that was great we can
actually look at the pods in a second
cousin yeah pretty cool encounter in
there so the Q beam seems like a great
way to kind of temporarily dream someone
max someone's max health in a way in an
indirect way it's exactly what it's like
yeah you're draining their max health
yeah so we have two different quests we
can do right now the cook I was talking
to the kitchen wants me to do something
and then we are trying to like gather
enough voice samples of this employee
Daniel show in order to like create like
a sequence of for a password to unlock
it a door somewhere else okay yeah so
your main goal is in another level
entirely but to get into that level you
have to trick a voice lock and to do
that you have to reconfigure or
reconstruct voice of any sounds applying
this this level
something in here called a poltergeist
oh yeah speaking of other hidden aliens
something she's like a gravity lift on
you yeah
so the poltergeist is all about
telekinesis are talking like a cactus
throw furniture and things that you
create it's also completely frozen
is trying to disappear right now now
that I've got it marked yeah you can use
your scoop to mark things and actually
help see you do that manually you know
okay cool
Sam so let's see I don't think I learned
any powers from it but poltergeist yet
so you walk into a room you see
furniture or something thrown at you you
start to say oh there's a poltergeist in
here what are some ways you can find it
like you just you saw like that aura
kind of that I had as I usually like in
corners and stuff well it'll pick up
physics objects and I'll throw them at
you okay and it will kind of like juggle
them in front of it so you kind of you
can kind of like see where it is because
it's going this is subject entity up
here's will appear briefly this time
just also like things like the that I
don't have any no wave transmitter is
left but the no transmitter I think will
also expose them and stuff okay you
could just start gluing at the air
yeah and just hope to hit actively
firing yeah it also perturbs the
environment as it passes things so like
sinks will turn on and toilets will
flush and stuff is a small spot cool
so just kind of exploring it here oh
yeah this area was breached
so this door is like closed and you just
can't get in here from this side but you
can go outside right and you can check
out this area so some of those crew pods
are actually floating in the void and
you can go out there
right okay cool
chef's as you like theoretically get
into a bunch of these rooms or some of
their just permanently locked we in
general we try not to permanently lock
anything so if you can see it you can
get to it as one of our philosophies in
it you can make things a little more
complicated but I think it pays off in
the end
okay it gives you a real feeling of a
palpable space that's the pneumix to the
folks looks like he had a painful death
yes so if you had if you had gone into
that crew quarters log will it tell you
that someone's dead before you even
discover their corpse or do you have to
see them I think you'll see life signs
look you throw myself just start hacking
right right
so again you could have gone and found
the key code to this or you can you have
the skill
torque on the actual secret alternate
entrance into the space yeah other parts
of the level it's always a good idea
there's like during demos yeah you think
I'm not sure I want to run into like a
poltergeist in like a gym with weights
everywhere or at all but especially in
again still live in the baby bag I know
I think turned that dick the ball okay
there she is oh that's her yep
she say she has dislocate to remember
yeah okay
found her treasure map trying to reach
jab but she's not yet so there's a
slight question vaulting him at for
instance so you could have found her
name in an email like that was an okay
very cool
she'd a treasure map on it yes there's a
sort of uh Kadeem D group on the station
oh cool huh and their game master set up
a little treasure quest for them
you should have good vantage point of
the pool and telepathic lurking in the
depths of the gym yeah so even though we
don't like we're not really expecting
players to ghost this game or anything
like we don't really we didn't go deep
on self we still have some some notions
that players will want to take advantage
of you know being tactical right so like
you know determine for yourself the the
terms of your engagement with these
enemies so yeah it's a good idea to like
do a little recon you can use your scope
and you can mark them all and you can
get them all like kind of on your hood
so it's easier to track them yeah and
then you can tell they score sneak
attacks by hitting them before they're
aware of you yeah it looks like I was
gonna take two things you can either use
the Q beam to overload one and then
chain it to the others or you could do
the like a sigh packs are what was it
yeah a second shock it's like a shock to
will that also just hurt others in the
vicinity mm-hmm are you can kinetic
blast them or recycles yep this doesn't
have a lure so I want to try to see if I
can maybe separate them the slower
make something down there yeah they're
moving towards it
this could give me an opportunity to
take out these uh these folks I can
refill them okay
like well no bosses just tell her now
it's on she made that far less dangerous
than it could have been yeah sure
oh it's a dream swimming pool I just
noticed he just used that kinetic blast
on you yeah it was cool lot lasted it
was almost a good run you stayed a
quicksave fairly recently right yeah
this is a totally optional area so I can
just not go there okay yeah yo it to up
next yeah yeah so you'd be able to
there was a rest bar in restaurants yeah
sort of a lounge area for the crew
members to blow off steam pass
I think I'm never gonna get used to that
I startle really easily and now I'm on
the lookout for poltergeists and
phantoms and the minister's gonna creep
up on me type of material and conclusive
knocking calibration requests so it this
thing has certain kind of psycho scope
tech built into it
Regina No
and it will sell like it that's how it
knows to a fire on the typhoon right but
when I approached it it said like that
like it's scan of me was inconclusive
mm-hmm and in the beginning before you
have any alien powers it doesn't say
anything like that it's just like yeah
you're fine right but as you start to
install as you start to install alien
powers we have this little meter on the
bottom right there of like how much type
of material you have in your system so
this the station just starts to turn on
you think you're an alien yeah yeah
that's great so like so you'll start to
worry about hurts more if you use is
that how many like alien upgrades you go
for or how much you use alien power it's
how many alien powers you stole okay
cool and so you can see like I can I can
hack turrets even though like well
they're friendly there's no business you
look there's any reason to yeah but if
you kind of do it early then later like
when they start turning on you then
those will be still being able to you
okay so that's what so that's why you
were mentioning earlier there are ways
of the world will kind of give itself
will respond to you yeah that just a
microphone I think it was like a shock
is like an overly powerful alien power
key here's a dynamic really like wasting
resources but but sometimes it's like
it's right there it's on the left rear
girl to do is press it make that problem
go away
you can see this area's really dark and
this thing it doesn't have power yeah
it's behind you
just become something else already yeah
I think they hide this problem solve
yeah nice so this area is part of the
one of the quest line to to reconstruct
the voice based on samples you find in
the world one of them is you know a song
that this band recorded exactly as part
of a new Roma demonstration they didn't
know any musical they've been having
musical skills or aptitude then they
installed near a mouse to show that held
like these people can play music oh cool
I know kung foo okay bass guitar cool or
keytar in this case alright um which is
there's probably a pretty cool audio log
of that song I like you actually a scene
here shortly
cool and like the person who's on the
auto log is the one who's like voice
activates is the key for summer exactly
yeah you're planning you know samples of
her all throughout the station this is
sort of like following her life okay
kind of unfolding or unpacking who she
was but the sound attracts attention oh
so now you got like a soundtrack to your
firefight basically holding your set
recorder while here
[Music]
no wait myself
typical doubt until it like fully
records it's her voice yeah you've got
kind of a countdown to luck they're kind
of a cool organic way to do like a
defensive situation
[Music]
ha it's like a Tarantino see wait run
away the song that is super jex opposed
against what's happening dead kid
thank you good call
[Music]
yeah so I use that lure grenade which
peels us over cut them off and kind of
like that written from the right to
fight with a little bit of a practical
thing I've been a fair shot on nebula
grant he said elite Linux what what did
I say not only greater mimic sorry oh
sorry about the Hollanders okay please
Yannick like more believable things well
they they are like stronger game or
health
thank you more damage
yeah they will grab
[Music]
the Phantom's have this behavior where
they will sometimes just like disappear
yeah and like not like the mimics what
they turned in think they just go and
they kind of hide yeah and and then just
like kind of waiting to like spring and
ambush on me and I really have no idea
where this guy but I see that light
flickering so he could be in there
because the Phantom's have this kind of
aura around around them where they
effect lights
well that's Errol I'm gonna set up a
trap and instead of the trap here and
seeping in my mouth
Oh
no no I feel good good trap yeah was
that a recycler yeah that was I put a
recycler charge down and I got sucked
into it so you became crafting materials
yeah that was great
you do this right again no problem that
this one was stylish it's um - place
that's infertility geek on recycler its
it does a huge amount of damage for some
things it will be just brothers it was
just like mass per day or for you I mean
or it's still same thing just a lot of
damage okay you can also get a chipset
that will make you a lot more resistant
to the graphical gravity well the
[Music]
he's calling Linux now which are going
to become fiery and they're going to
come after me
[Music]
[Music]
I picked it away
the way those mimics became more
phantoms or the mimics and selfish I'd
like to fight the power to Daniel right
here clip on fire that's okay
[Music]
I like the eighties retro feel of this
song yeah that sort of 80s retro sense
kind of like permeates the game yeah
yeah what when is this set it's set in
2035 okay okay you know with a sort of a
retro aesthetic that kind of tints
everything sure before I hit the music
I'm gonna set some traps up yeah I like
how they fold up do you have any Ramones
to get fortify yeah I was gonna think of
the same thing still ever insufficient
type of material could you theoretically
create like a barrier of like a glue
wall to kind of funnel them into one
specific shooting zone oh yeah or like
they bust through that very easily the
bill generally try to path around it
they'll try to find an alternate way but
if they're trapped behind it they will
attack it okay
break through so I just fortified this
turret which gives it like refills as
health and gives it extra health okay
and so it seemed a little bit more
robust against the aliens culture
there's one of situations where it was
almost more fun to die because then you
know what's coming and you can plan for
exactly yeah let's see how they do
you're like doing tower defense right
now with that turret and that sorry I
lead back home I feel like
know how he's shooting already for the
window I'd say kinetic glass would be
good for their little health it'd be
good to go okay
[Music]
hi
that seemed so satisfying
[Music]
he's a burger
is there a historical in-game reason for
why everything's kind of an 80s pinch is
that just like I was just kind of
curious Kennedy sir but I guess if
that's like sticking with the golden age
you could get any survived we never did
okay protected son played
[Music]
I actually don't mind hearing the song
over and over again because I love it
it's really good
yeah who did you have do that is that
like some outside artist so this was
actually our own aria and sound engineer
of Matt Piersol and Rothko and Tony our
creative director kind of worked
together on that okay but the sound the
rest of the music in the game is
composed by Mick Corden okay we did the
team Sandra
oh okay awesome so he totally like
changed kind of it's like you know the
sound from like mental stuff to synth
wave damn that's awesome but the guy's
got some rage yeah I know like Raph did
his own music in the past right oh yeah
that's what that question of my favorite
song is this is a system mist and do I
have the toy gun on this build no I
don't but another good use of the the
toy darts is um is like you can get
these things to kind of pop and they
kind of cradle these little sis codes
and the sisters will kind of follow in
agreeance moving and so the you can
shoot the Flexi phone bolts and they'll
kind of go after that and chase it okay
good always stirring and one of them
isolated is pretty harmless but when you
get a swarm of you know half a dozen or
more of them at one time it can be
really dangerous okay yeah we have
especially in zero-g we track the
players radiation level and so when that
fills up you get radiation poisoning and
there's some negative effects associated
with that okay so there's like ways to
decrease that to the radiation yeah
there's we have like um we have medical
operators that will refill your health
and kind of restore this okay there's
also some pills I think I picked them up
earlier I know those in psychotronics
okay there ain't your ads yeah so you
can just use these and get reducing your
irritation level down cool
so rich has like level designer give a
favorite area in the game that's near
and dear to your heart um I'm trying to
think I really like this level because
it allows us to have this range of
storytelling like looking at the human
aspect and it's much slower pace than a
lot of the rest of the game basically
you're kind of like creeping around and
snooping in people's quarters and stuff
like that I like the exterior a lot and
the guts level because it's zero-g and
it sort of showcases that sort of unique
aspect really well I like those a lot
it's a separate about you or any areas
that you think you would do cooler stuff
in than others passport um you we're all
uh I mean as the you can return to areas
with with stuff that you get later sure
and like then there's more stuff
available you know I think I probably
spend the most time in hardware labs
because one because it's pretty early
and two because it just has so many
systems like setups with crazy things in
them yeah so that's kind of like a
playground sandbox for me you have to
say as like a systems designer there's
few kinds of games of me I feel like
more fun but also complicated to work on
just like an immersive sim it's a little
overwhelming but it's also super fun and
yeah it's just this is what this is kind
of this is why I got into gaming
assisted work stuff like this this is a
dream that's what I that's what I'm like
ever since dishonored the first one in
2012 it kind of reignited this love for
immersive Sims you know like the
Bioshock games had some elements of
those and you know there's like Far Cry
2 state of decay but Dishonored seems
will be the one that not only
established arcane but also bring back
this kind of gave me a big way now you
have zelda doing emergent gameplay of
Metal Gear Solid 5 did it and it seems
like the people make it an hour the
people that grew up playing like thief
and system shock and origin looking
blaster definitely because the audience
for those back in the day the 90s before
Looking Glass in origin both shuttered
was kind of you know in the Deus Ex and
ion storm
Austin but the audience for those there
were like kind of cult classics cuz I
feel like yeah it was just a smaller
like niche kind of you know PC crowd
that might not have been affected
gaming was was a hobby I mean it was it
was like a hobby right like now it's
mainstream yeah it's like like so many
people game now and and something that
has been a mission for us is to make
this kind of game mainstream
yeah like bring this to a larger
audience without dumbing it down while
reducing the complexity and richness of
it I think games like dayz and minecraft
really brought that sort of system's
driven kind of thing to the masses and a
bigger way and then bringing that
background to the first-person shooters
and RPGs and
like that became kind of a natural
consequence of that sure so the coolest
part is finding your own stories to tell
rather than this layer and a constructed
narrative on the developers part not
that that's not here as well but it's
almost kind of like you know Dungeons &
Dragons shared authorship which is
pretty cool yes I think that's when when
games weren't the best is when they are
that kind of you know cooperative sort
of storytelling sure absolutely yeah and
obviously Harvey who did some like super
vision on this game and whatnot and like
creative input after he was done with
this honor - or throughout and I know
obviously he worked on Deus Ex and QA on
System Shock 1 or 2 I believe - I
believe and then graphical Antonio spent
a lot of time at origin and before doing
arcane in 2000 before arcs faecalis came
yeah heat intercept Alice in Dark
Messiah it was also very system
stripping game so oh boy oh my gosh oh
wait a minute was this thing the
nightmare um did you install alien
powers
yeah I've been installing alien powers
so another consequence a lot for juicing
up on alien powers is this thing will
eventually come and hunt you um god I've
got an app so you cross that threshold
station is not trusting you anymore
everything man still crawling to the
door it's about to okay this is about to
get really ugly so the nightmare tracks
you more the more you use the power the
more you make yourself alien basically
and I want you there are certain
thresholds basically yeah when you pass
those and like it you're kind of
awakening this thing right you're
getting its attention are the more than
one nightmares are not the same one this
is like a persistent threat it's kind of
a persistent right you can't get rid of
it for a time but it'll always come back
Hey what - yeah it's like a ring rate
when you put on the ring it's just
exactly Indra we like to think of it
kind of like a like
took the t-rex or something progressed
part it's just yeah Oh Fred all right
just get right in his face it respects
that yeah
no-no-no
[Applause]
put your arms above your head look
larger than you are a little scared the
black bear it's how it just feared me so
it's really hard to aim when you get
feared by the nightmarish so how long
would you be if you were if you weren't
electing to fight him right now how long
would you be building from the inner
fiends chasing you oh I've never had
there's a countdown timer yes yeah so I
can't just like go hide
but like you kill these things it's a
huge reward
I got him okay so you dropped a lot of
valuable stuff yeah there's just tons of
material to this guy alien materials
that you can use to like create your
mods and stuff so there's a recycler
appear we eventually get a fabrication
plant for new robot so you can make your
own okay on a flip side though you use a
lot of mo you might not have otherwise
correct yeah exactly it's a bit of a
trade-off okay we definitely won't have
a scarcity of ammo and things like that
share schemes in education yeah all
these blots
it's like tuner mods worth of blocks
okay so it's pretty worthwhile
[Music]
please pick up a notepad or something
that had that key code yes now I can
hear a poltergeist crash somewhere
that's right cuz you didn't finish the
one in there yeah where showed yeah
exactly
I was gonna show the same one the same
poltergeist though there was another one
that was in here yes he didn't get a
chance to kill oh I was gonna show off
this this fun trick for the poltergeist
because I learned this ability called
remotely violation from the from
scanning the poltergeist and what that's
what it uses to pick up things and throw
them at you mm-hmm so I was gonna try to
show off but then the nightmare kind of
rude my plans so how excited are you
guys for Friday or even tomorrow when
you start to see the crazy ways people
are playing with these systems a
tremendously and we generally gather
around at the office and why yeah you
know streamers or whatever and just see
what kinds of things people come up with
that was interesting yeah it's it's
around here somewhere there it is yeah
yes it's always it's always novel and
exciting to see when people get their
hands on these things and because as
exciting as it is like after dishonor to
to watch all the like insane like speed
runs and chaining people are doing with
those and I think I recall Harvey saying
the team hadn't necessarily thought
about creating to avoid falling damage
they would put a decoy down there that
jump on their own decoy but I'm as much
as like that's fun for me to watch I
can't imagine how thrilling that is for
you guys to see how people are playing
with these tools that you made yes it's
great and having having played and been
so close to beginning for this long like
seeing it out in the wild in other
people's hands is very refreshing
because like me you know I I can't taste
it anymore basically it's like I knew
let me use released an hour or
supposedly hour long demo and people
already did something that you're like
out we didn't really account for that
too much we could vent the bank shot
thing yeah well it's the system's
account for it but when you really some
oh you're like oh man we didn't think of
that yeah be kind of account for not
accounting for it they sure yeah well
said Oh need again with this guy huh
that's a more efficient way there okay
oh so that kinetic dad just yeah sign
nullify now so I'm gonna have trouble
use my powers I think hasn't been do
enough damage to actually sell it
but oh man uh-uh
that's about the hour mark are we uh are
we running a time where we can we can
keep going as long as you want to I
don't know how much more you want to
show and before you get toward uh things
you're either not planning on showing or
just spoilers or whatnot but yeah key
point
okay go they're bringing them and maybe
uh exterior yeah oh that's really good
good yeah let's show off some some
zero-g stuff okay have you shown that
off yet a little bit here and there just
a tiny bit okay
this door leads right to 0zg suffer use
on your way there yeah good passes to
the urban which is the sort of green
space like a bit ostentatious like you
know look we've got trees in space and
look how much money and hour we have
they serve like a function in terms of
providing oxygen yeah yeah they are the
oxygen recycling stuff uses the trees as
well okay so it's kind of a dual purpose
thing cool aesthetically this game just
fight like being on the space station
seems really diverse or being on this
one space station to see adversity like
knowing that zero-g two is pretty
enticing yeah there are teams done a
really great job I mean they're also
like he's layer so you've got like the
Cold War era you know origins of the
station or you've got the sort of neo
deco stuff is kind of layer on the top
of that as raishin came in and took over
this old research facility
so close I like this kind of a lot the
cue beam and then just draining the rest
of the health and is still there oh okay
I was awesome yeah wait what happened
there's like you shattered the glass
I think I'd even know that was very cool
closet they're like I know this is for
Clark this is where careful it's
important if you stopped in this little
tripping bird sounds piped in and things
like that
oh cool here is their wildlife at all
they're just like it missed the sky
well presented here okay all run good I
was gonna like use me make this Delphi
that guy but this area is just so
hospital now
did something you do make that area more
hostile I think it's just later on in
the campaign you just had yet to go yeah
okay if it comes out it's going to get a
face full of recycling aid
the Phantom's will totally use those
crap shafts so okay like you can you can
account for it
cool I'm pretty sure if you throw a TP
grenade grab chef they turn off they
shut off and things fall down them yeah
so if there's a long one you can make a
neat trick a phantom of the following
you through it oh and you EMP it like
you've an EMP charge like inside of it
and then it goes in and it triggers a
peach are just turns off the grabbed
shaft and we could go off and then fall
yeah that's cool yeah or you can just
keep yet prevented from following yeah
yeah I think it's like a voltaic phantom
will do that to you too if you're trying
to escape in the drive shaft like that
it's stuff shorts out to grab stuff and
use for a hot damn
okay we're going Co G 0 G stuff yeah so
we really wanted are like 0 G think
stuff to fulfill the fantasy of what it
would be like to fly around in space so
we put the work in to make sure that the
player can roll okay because we've
noticed some most games that have any
kind of your outside you know you're in
space or whatever there's still a
constant up and down and so by letting
the player roll it totally changes the
way you experience a space because
without that fixed frame you know you
just you can get disoriented really
quickly okay
but that's part of the fun in partner
fantasy
shuttle over there it is yeah so part of
the challenge of designing the levels
for this we're making sure that they all
kind of fit inside the shell of the
station and that you can go out and in
and out and it's oh yeah go to that
shuttle yeah you can't head there now so
it's not even all on the space station
crack again yeah there are bits nice
Easter's orbiting the station
yeah we didn't we didn't really talk
about or agreed to showing this that's
not foreboding at all but I know people
are curious about zero-g combat so the
games coming out so soon and I thought
let's just do a little tease
I think there's something out here this
coral right so that would lead one to
believe there might be a weaver
you might not be here at this point in
the campaign yeah that's maybe it's not
here
yeah it's not here okay maybe someone
already killed whoever made the safe
that we use command Brazil that's right
could you go inside that shuttle if you
wanted to oh yeah there's some stuff in
there and like off to the left and right
you've got the hardware labs and
psychotronics and when you in my
division you can actually see the levels
as they protrude from them sort of shell
there will they only show up on your UI
at this point if you bend it they they
don't show up on the UI but like they're
all labeled on the exterior like a Cobra
lab and then the airlocks are labeled
with a point of interest markers okay
and if you unlock the airlock from the
inside then you can go in from the
outside so they're sort of like one-way
fast travel kind of that fast travel to
share shortcuts basically
I'll so if you pull out too fast into
things you'll damage your suit hey Mike
support don't guys no no this whole time
nobody can okay figure now
so will you find Arthur there are a lot
of like typhoons that will be out in 0g
or are they all okay there are some yeah
but like the big floating ones and just
ords and things like that can navigate
in in space this is my favorite things
to do in space you're stacking it enough
for that like yeah like I signed what
that is yeah we tried to adhere to the
holders no sound in space yeah yeah that
fantasy is really important
yeah as soon as they are logged back
into hardware labs for instance
so are one of these hull breaches on the
outside of station theoretically that
one you saw earlier yes that's the one
you see though this is it okay so now
you're on the other side of that door
cool yeah and oh that's why you this is
this is when you see in the opening like
hour of the game okay
and then the other ones like up if there
isn't up psychotronics reach was it
there was one in crew quarters
okay psychotronics also has one as well
okay a lot of levels have like parts of
them that are exposed to vacuum that you
can go out and then do something and
come back in I just presumably like
we're aliens tried escaping or some sort
that I the hull breaches have some
narrative a lot of narrative
underpinnings you know something bad
happened you know that some gas main was
ruptured or some aliens did something
okay well I was just kind of an excuse
to play with the exterior interior
relationship yeah
and we've also got a full use dynamic
Sun cycle so things will be bright or
dark depending where the sun's at
[Music]
so this era this there here's an airlock
into the power plant but it's locked
so the airlocks I'll start locked from
the end you have to unlock them from the
inside so you have to once you're in
power plant you can unlock interlocked
and then you can use it to come back and
go back and forth between other levels
so yep there is we're tell there we go
drop on it
[Applause]
you guys I'm what's up I'm getting
critical hits and we have a we do have
like some some amount of RPG stuff to do
like how we do damage so there are
critical hits and you can like level up
your arms to increase your crit rate and
stuff okay
thanks for the drifting there's a set
that that was the death animation for
when you're flooding yeah you just kind
of float away thing that might be a good
place to end it right there okay cool
awesome man I'm excited for that
I feel like we asleep robably haven't
really breached the surface too much of
what yeah we were just scratching at the
surface yeah I'm really excited for
people to get this game get their hands
on this and really to start digging into
it yeah I mean we saw with the opening
our demo how many people really you know
they they really challenged our concept
of opening our yeah I saw some people
who like it's it's a they it's been like
15 hours on it so we will just played it
two or three times or whatever and some
people just even like they spent three
or four hours just playing them once
so yeah the like this game is gonna have
a lot to do with your relationship to
content like how much do you want to
delve into everything how much do you
want to explore everything and read
everything and yeah so those players are
going to have a long a lot a lot to dig
their teeth into you yeah a lot of
rewarding experimentation everything and
exploring yeah a lot of the stuff we
touched on here wasn't even like a plot
or a story related you know the main
quest wasn't even really a thing we were
just gonna playing around and yeah
that's up like that projecting a mob ad
just cuz you saw her name and an email
and then this whole like dungeons
dragons literally dungeons and dragons
quests yes coming up that's awesome yeah
it's very player driven questing yeah so
Friday well I mean like tomorrow starts
in Australia people can start playing
this game there's a time here but I yeah
for all intensive purposes Friday May
5th ps4 Xbox one PC pray from Arkane
Studios would be out set Shane thank you
so much for joining us thank you in rich
Wilson thank you thanks this has been
awesome I had a lot of fun I can't wait
this but for everybody joining on
YouTube or twitch or GameSpot thank you
so much for joining us we'll have more
pray whatever review and progress up as
soon as possible once we get our hands
on the game tomorrow in the UK we'll be
reviewing it will have a full review up
hopefully sometime next week well if I'm
sure features coming out and maybe like
a live stream or two so stay tuned you
get about four more we'll see you next
time
[Music]